>> There''s one last thing I want
to demonstrate with operators, and
that's how the increment and
decrement operators effect assignment.
We'll start by creating a few variables.
And we'll also create a variable
that adds all of these together.
So, right now our total
pounds is equal to 4.
Now, if I use the increment or decrement
operator in front of a variable,
then it's applied before any other
operators in this expression.
And that includes
the assignment operator.
So, if we do plus, plus pounds of flour,
then our total pounds is
now 5 because the increment
is applied before assignment.
And we can check to see the new
value of pounds of flour,
which is 2 after being incremented.
Now, if instead I move the increment or
decrement operator after the variable it
modifies, then it's applied after
the other operators in this expression.
And that, again, includes assignment.
So, in this case, we've put the
increment operator after poundsOfflour
and our totalPounds is still
the original 4 pounds.
But we can see that pounds of
flour has been incremented to 2.
It just happened after
the assignment of total pounds.
So, you'll want to be extra careful
when you use these increment and
decrement operators
because of this nuance.
So, I'd encourage you
to take some time and
play around with them on a playground
until you feel really comfortable.